Magda Nell who unfortunately has had to
attend a funeral out of town today
hopefully he will be back in
not-too-distant future so when somebody
ought to move those apologies be
sustained please move counselor MacPhail
Signet counselor Phillips all those in
favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
Thank You counselors so also just want
to take a minute to introduce a new face
on on the screen today Carla Brothers
and Carlo has just started working for
the council in a corporate support role
and will have but to do with council as
time goes on so she's come on today just
to see who you are and just to get to
know a little bit more about the
processes that that we use in local
government which for some people can be
a little bit ponderous I have to say and
but I'm sure that Carla you will enjoy
it and look forward to working with you
into the future right now let's kick off
this afternoon by item 1 item 2 solid
waste bylaw and this is a piece of
legislation that we need to be
progressing quickly and we have Keith
with us today will they may not
recognize Keith under all that we're
here but welcome along Keith and and I
just want to get you to preps introduced
us and took us through the the
particular item thank you your worship
this is one of the more straightforward
reports that I've done in recent times
and is really relatively simple matter
in terms of the current waste bylaw that
we have in places was due for review in
2018 and it automatically gets revoked
if it's not replaced by a new bylaw by
the 1st of July this year so the purpose
of my report is really just to set out
the the background to it that it's been
agreed that they
we'll be a joint bylaw prepared between
the Southland councils and a waste
advisory group was set up to do that and
work started on the bylaw and went into
abeyance a little bit at the beginning
of last year but started off again
towards the end of last year and was
progressing quite well and then the cove
at 19 came along and staff resources
were directed elsewhere so in terms of
the process that we've got before us the
path of least resistance is to reaffirm
the 2008 bylaw as a temporary measure
until such time as the new joint bylaw
is drafted put out for consultation and
adopted by the three councils it is a
three-step process that council needs to
go through first council needs to be
satisfied that the bylaw is the most
appropriate way of addressing the issues
that we have with waste and really that
is from an administrative and a
regulatory point of view and secondly
that the draft bylaw is circulated with
some minor changes in it from previous
is also appropriate and council needs to
resolve to undertake a fairly short
consultation process which in this case
being short is quite appropriate because
really the status quo is continuing I'm
happy to respond to any questions people
may have well thank you Thank You Keith
I think it's you've explained it very
well
just before I open up for discussion as
chief exec that Steve do you want to
make any any comment to this item
you're on mute soup just really to see
the main event really is the waste get
inspired I reviewed bottle is not far
away but to ensure we hear a full tips
of regulators available to us throughout
the next few months and particularly
given that we are now moving into a new
regime for curbside recycling at least
some period we have an effective boiler
on place and this particular initiative
ensures that we will have that but it
may only have a short life of several
months before a far more expensive and
reviewed while or comes forth from
wasting Hey thank you
okay so we have the item before us a
recommendation which is made up of three
parts we also have a copy of the
proposed bylaw attached to the item it
to me it looks like it's very
straightforward and we just need to
progress us as quickly as we possibly
can and open for discussion or proposal
and end or amendment so is there any
questions of councillors just a week
spelling mistake on page thirteen
fourteen point four just talking about
fifteen vehicles has got more such
vehicles as directed by the council I
think it's move such councils just going
here thank you
you wish to I think it's appropriate
that we moved the esteemed the prison by
law albeit a draft by law until waste it
produces a new updated regional vile
officer
most sensible way forward and I'd be
happy to move the recommendation okay
you're moving the three recommendations
I'll move for three recommendations do I
have a seconder for accounts the grant
don't okay so it has been moved and
seconded
there's there any discussion on that on
that proposed action there's not I'm
going to put that motion it was in favor
please say aye and raise your hand
against the motion is carried
Thank you Thank You counselors right
we're on now to item 3 which is the
council budget and we have a whole set
of very unusual situations facing us as
a as a council but also as a community
and as a nation and I'm sure that
everyone is very aware of those those
challenges and the challenges that are
unfolding on a on a daily basis before
you you have a memo from the chief
executive proposing a budget for council
for the for the next 12 months beginning
on the 1st of July and that is up for
discussion this afternoon but before I
open that up for discussion I would ask
the chief exec that just to make any
comments that he would like to in terms
of getting to the point that we are at
today and any points of guidance that
you would like to give to council now is
the budget preparation process really
had two phases you say it was the
pre-flood sin curve at 19 where we
thought we were looking at a reasonably
high rate increase like a lot of
councillors envisioned trying to
responsibly end both in regard to
for natural obligations but also in to
change the work program an obligation in
Vivaldi identity to continue for by
those and then with the floods but think
nineteen in the fast-paced changes to
the economic climate really behave the
staff and obviously the counselors as
well when we've had I think three
workshops on estimates and we've been
peering our way over the last two months
so trying to drill down to the lowest
possible amount but at the same time
make it sustainable and at the same time
also acknowledge they've been requests
in the community that have come to the
council for position also having a
mind's eye to the capacity review that
accounts and talked about 18 months ago
some specific recommendations that the
council endorsed again about nearly 18
months ago Nia and they and part have
found their way through the process
perfect storm there are some commits
again the council at p2 so great South
and the transition to fully funding the
council's share of great South
contribution both for poor a contract
funding her family way now it's
important financial year insurance
premiums have increased and making that
a given and there are also some itix
because which a result of ordered an
arrest overview of that particular area
can a need for granite investment so we
come to you today you work with the we
thought was a two point six four percent
rate increase and then the late-breaking
development is your Liberty which seems
to cure on daily basis with email to be
saying it can't go any further worthy
reasonably long-standing arrangement
it's the trust fund 25 percent of the
basically the rate pair requirement for
the in
tea event center that's the portion it
cannot be recovered from fees and
charges so that's put rates up about
point one teen I have in my report
alluded to there are potentially food
games that can be made but they are that
become a cost cost of either elongation
or caste or political or community
only elected members can weigh those up
and I refer specifically to the
community strategy manager position the
Tasik mister keuner
the position provider for which is part
one but provide four for six months of
the year and I've also referred to fear
ordering the replacement of the general
manager community all those areas if
they were all pretty hell it is really
is mister way out but I guess we've got
two points any worship both in terms of
the matching timeline to have the annual
plan presented the doctor for the
council by the end of June and making
these judgments we cannot make a staff
we need the council now to come and he
never saw written about what's and
what's out and what might be acceptable
from overall financial perspective both
in the eyes of elected members is
evidence of the organization and the
public that we serve will change the
range of services expect but also the
fiscally responsible result and it's
unfortunate but you seem to be
frozen and time on the screen and well
we can hear you okay we can see we can
see an image of you but it's not a live
image so maybe you need to refresh your
screen but we can certainly hear what
you're saying so thank you
well that and welcome along Stuart it's
good to have you back on on board so
we're just on item three which is
beginning the council budget I think
councilors we've had a lot of giving and
throwing on this and and you read in
that and the narrative from the chief
executive we we really began this dis
competition around what the budget will
look like sitting at a 6.7% increase
which is pretty scary and one that
certainly wasn't going to be a go from
any way shape or form or in any way
shape or form for this council I believe
that we have worked through the
challenges and and looked at some of the
opportunities that we have and have got
to a pretty responsible place for the
council to to move forward so that it's
in a position to not just fulfill its
obligations from a legal perspective but
also to be active and capable of making
changes and encouraging innovation in
our community I think that we were at
now is it's a good spot and while there
could be three other cuts of the
council's of a mind I think that if we
do go through that process then we'll
lose quite a bit of capability for the
council in the community to to recover
in the long term or both in the short
term and the long term actually because
the the areas where there are
opportunities I believe are ones that
ones that would react and would prove
invaluable to the challenge that Cove
inflicted upon us but if this is open
for discussion and and/or amendment so
I'll turn that over to Council now and
welcome any comment that many counselors
might have so who's going to be first
counselor hosted then counselor Gabon
yeah thanks your worship I guess I guess
when looking at this I'm a little bit
torn would be nice to be delivering a 0%
rate increase to the community but also
the council is probably in a privileged
position where it can provide employment
opportunities in the community that's
losing so many also you probably echo
your comment a zero percent rate
increase this year is going to be a
significant rate increase in the 2021
budget when we get around the table in a
year's time officer ever see an increase
for in for a probably quite a wake-up
call so we do need to to have something
modest and I think that's what we here
before us
I've got a couple of minor questions but
I'll just ask them of the chief
executives the the the base rate the
base rate increase in there Steve of
286,000 I guess I guess that's comparing
to LTP as opposed to F current financial
reality a budget that was set to three
years ago as opposed to what our current
cost structures in place is that showing
a well increase the staff or is it just
showing what we're we're currently in
current show them okay I'm sorry
that's showing what we're currently in
Kieran not desired both in spring okay
and I still to trace here is it just dig
oh it's just Steve I like yeah I can
just a couple of other ones that the
corporate HR position and the animal
control composition Agena positions I
would perhaps question but again I think
the risk does bring that percentage
increase down to low I prefer to leave
it in the chief executives hands to to
manage you know the next twelve months
are going to be interesting the involved
so pretty comfortable with where it is
in terms of the management accountant
country position and community strategy
position that I guess
this is the year that the council should
be supporting those positions and my
view so I'm supportive of those I'm just
lastly on page 22
is it a typo from mr. Pearson we've got
a corporate organization them Tara
licensee trust write it at the council
saying they had a story - it 2020s been
has been shut for Gore has he been the
victim of spell checker or does he or
she may met I don't know there's still
another derived yeah really yeah pretty
pretty shocked if that's the that's the
way they're corporates communicate to
counsel I'll shut up now thank you for
it now look you race racing good points
and we've got John and then Brahma on
the same both wage increases whether
that was on for this year and it's been
answered but most corporates are seeing
lists are voluntary taking twenty to
twenty five percent reductions for six
months across the board to see what
happens we need to be aware of that
because it's happening happening in our
own community and depends how we pan out
of us will make six months next year's
budget may need to have some harder
screw cool or locks in it before we go
and pass it I do have a question about
the animal part-time animal person to
whether we should delay that till we
actually see the income coming from
dog registrations leaks to 25,000 and we
need his actual we could employ the
person it's not query or put on is we
keep and increasingly at budget however
wise is gonna be bigger next year I
think there's gonna be a flood on effect
until next year's increases agree to
Dear John and just on the dog control
one and I'm not sure if you're with us
at the moment Steve enough but if
perhaps you can just speak a little bit
to why that needs to happen this year we
desirable which comes out of the dog
action plan and it's actually funded by
a proposed
trophy rearrangements that was put in
with but aspirational is not suitable
but I think we've got a bit of a
challenge here and it's quite critical
that we have to achieve achieve it up in
a position where we can answer these
questions and we can understand what
he's saying I think we might just time I
hope or units and see if we can sort out
the technical difficulties that it still
is having and then will recommence the
meeting as soon as possible so so Sonia
do we need to do something there with
the recording to stop this at the moment
just remind counselors that while we are
not in meeting in the formal meeting
this is being recorded and as I
understand it would be like so just
remind you of that excuse me while I go
and see what I can do this
we're castles we should see the
Civitavecchia very soon but he wanted
the wrong name because well we call some
grouping for the sake at this meeting
you know appears there's been a problem
with his step which is always a bit of a
risk I guess
[Music]
which one here yet yet fine yep yep okay
so we'll lift you Steve I was just
asking if you were ever heads up on
where things are at with the dog control
proposal this year it's not critically
important it's desirable to point that
part-time officer as a result of the dog
action plan that was established about
two years ago to be fear it's a position
that's been proved to be hard to fill
but would it seriously undermine our
ability to deliver an effective dog
control service no and as I say only
aspirational so it can it can come out
of the budget but it was the intention
my understanding with that position was
going to be covered more by fees and
rates but in terms of principle and
being seen to be doing the right things
I think it could easily be packed to one
side no not at all because is the
emphasis is on education and advice not
on delivering the essential service of
dog control in the district okay I think
I'm getting a sense that there's a no
real imperative to have that talked
about or to include it in in this year's
Gyptian to that to just remove that for
this 12-month group okay so we move on
to other items and brahmanah you wanted
to raise something
oh you're immune from yep thank you your
worship just want to say thanks to
Steven Donna for the good work that
they've done I know they've been
beavering away quite some time and it's
looking really good and I mean I'm
complete agreement that I know nobody
likes paying their rates and we all moan
about it but at the end of the day we've
got services to provide ending people to
employ so bitter a small increase now
than a bigger one down the track but I
did have a query of Steve about the
email T if that was possible please and
another comment Steve I was just
wondering the amount that email T have
got listed in the elitists of seventeen
thousand four hundred and twenty three
percent an annual payment or a quarterly
one three through your worship it's it's
a quarterly one however that quarter was
extraordinarily high because it included
some maintenance and the event center so
it wouldn't normally be that high what
we budget for is around thirty three
thousand dollars per year from the MLT
for the projected twenty five percent of
rape pair and put required to run the
center thank you
and my other comment was about the
community strategy person and also the
tacit country I think we need those the
expertise from those people to sort of
lead the way forward given that we want
to attract visitors and permanent
residents and and also the fact that the
tacit country position at this part is a
six-month contract and I'm sure there
could be reviewed if we felt that it was
a an unnecessary cost so I'm all in
agreement with it thank you yes look I
think to go from six point seven one to
what will now be below two point eight
four was an extraordinary result I see
the chief executive and staff have
looked at a lot of areas and and refined
and give them particular scrutiny
conscious that the overall inference for
air motiva spending is as a requirement
from central government to maintain
roads water and wastewater and upgrade
them so to be doing that at the same
time and deliver a conservative rate
increases is a is a good result I do see
that we've got the benefit of reduction
and interest rates of 470 K and that's
been a big contribution I do think and
we've got a history of considered a
financial management here in court and
this is a example of it so I'm very very
comfortable with 2.8 for what will be
slightly below that is being able to
maintain their services in upgrading
infrastructure it's quite extraordinary
sound very comfortable I think yeah
thank you worship I wasn't able to be at
the last rates workshop so I'm sure
about what you would have discussed was
covered so I've got a couple of queries
so I won't be having too many events
hitman this positions counsel she could
do a fantastic country but unfortunately
Events Coordinator is cooperate in from
hospital and will be be off for for some
time in terms of of tussock country look
she could well because one day two could
be connected to that however and put
before she she lived for an operation
she was very connected and very valuable
in business recovery plan that we were
putting together
and so I think that there's a real role
for for that person and in the
foreseeable future and certainly in the
next six months anyway until we see
exactly where we are with the beans for
her to be very active in that space so
tell me exactly been what the tacit
country coordinator will do they'll do
it okay so who wants to speak to their
Rama thank you your worship
um Nikki I think the the biggest thing
that we've noticed is that this has the
fest of all has to be taken from a very
able base of volunteers going forward it
needs to be someone with a professional
background and connections and
advertising media social media all sorts
of things that we've probably no
disrespect to our event coordinators but
they just don't have that expertise and
working with the current person who's
been engaged to help has been quite an
eye-opener for all of us on that
committee and I really think if we don't
have someone that's professional and
able to do that it's going to fall flat
nuts face and we don't want that to
happen it's been been interesting
working along with that group just to
see how it's going to pan out and and I
have to say that when when I first
started meeting with them I thought this
is just a matter of coordinating what's
already there and it's not going to be
too to bigger job and the more you get
into it the more potential there is for
something very special for this part of
the world and and I think the the risk
of not doing it well is huge why and
that's in my mind well we need to have
the right person at the right time to
coordinate this and I think that what's
happened over the last six months in
preparation for this year which
unfortunately it could be canceled we
have witnessed a really good
professional doing a really good job
to the point that the bookings in intend
expressions of interest in this year's
fest of work you huge and I just
happened to hear today that the bookings
that the accommodation bookings for next
year are very heavy already in fact I
think there might be a lot of places
that already booked out with the
anticipation of what is going to happen
at tussock country next year so is there
a small role play for this financially
or do you follow in teams them to here's
the entire part one role so yeah I would
think that it so it's a six-month role
and it's funded along those lines at
this stage okay other questions queries
you had another question Nikki to do
about the community strategy manager
mm-hmm want to talk about that once -
sure um you know at the moment we have a
community strategy committee that really
needs an effective principal adviser the
there is no resource in this area so the
whole attention around business recovery
some work that we've been doing as best
as were able in the last few weeks with
a local business sector that would be a
champion by a community strategy manager
some of the issues that social issues
that may emerge and we're at were
evident prior to the covert 19
occurrence in terms of community
resilience and drugs in the community
that type of stuff this is an area where
a community strategy management would
work
so that's the other type of things
that's and that the whole economic
development Prout where the council
really hasn't had in the departure of
the two mural contract just no longer
has a presence the community strategy
managers deemed or concerned to be avoid
that that it can be thought and work
with the chairman of the community
strategy committee to come up with some
initiatives because currently what
happens is when these things to occur we
can't sprint for a while but all other
people have other jobs to do and then
revert back to their full-time role and
the focus is lost and then the issue
never really hits champion so that's the
purpose behind the community strategy
position so just a bit further on that
one Richard do you want to make any
comment is here of that particular
committee yeah I just had a few general
comments was they lead into that anyway
regarding support for what we're looking
at the moment obviously the landscapes
changed as we would come through
we're obviously sitting on that on rate
as it is at the moment and I think it is
credit to Steve in crew leader we've
managed to give them their position
although next year is going to be a
different story but we don't know if in
sync the changing so fast within our
local community environment and within
support around the community strategy
manager just in some of the commentary
I've had through the workshops in the
last month with business members people
amongst the community even up to today
talking to members of the business
community was a great deal of fear of
the unknown and what's more safety had
me we are seeing businesses
restructuring and going I would see that
this role would be key and important to
looking at those community opportunities
for businesses and the greater community
also looking those funding streams and
probably one of the big things that have
come out of those workshops was trying
to retain a capability and capacity
in town or else we're going to lose
things and I think once they're gone
they're gone and and we know that those
mural positions we had through the the
Gore development groups or the Community
Development
they provided a huge amount of paperwork
and a huge amount of leg work and
groundwork for projects which we have
actually brought back to the table to
put them for a central government when
we're looking at these tarnished rubble
private projects that we're trying to
try to get through so that we have
projects that we're just going to shout
if we don't have that input also we're
probably gonna have a business community
that you know it's just it just needs
that support and I know that sometimes
people look at these these positions as
luxuries but they're not a luxury though
I believe and stand by that's essential
we meet someone there in the community
the best the best thing we can get on
through councilors to get something on
the ground at the moment and stay strong
and hopefully keep ourselves together
just a closing comment in regard to
obviously tussock country and their and
their we don't know what what's ahead
for us we're seeing the groups of people
slowly increasing in size and we are
looking at a domestic tourism situation
that's probably developing that's
reasonably unknowing yet and we may be
onto something that will become bigger
than we actually understand we may be
working in an environment that's that's
leading into a tourist sort of
destination and it will need
professional management and and
knowledge to achieve that I don't think
it's a part-time fly-by-night position
just regarding MLT to the commentary
with the letter that's been tabled by a
CEO I'm just hoping that um as the books
go through that into the next financial
year they'll open them up and maybe
there may be something there because I
think there has been them a bit of
business around town and I appreciate
what the CEO said but I hope they're not
closing the book in regard to the MLT of
the in-center I hope that up if there is
some money
that comes online them I we reconsider
and later quarters thank you Richard in
just in terms that letter comment around
email T but you know we've had a long
history of working collaboratively with
with the NR T and we will continue that
and every way shape or form that we can
I appreciate the challenge that they
have and I'm looking forward to meeting
with both the chief exec defender the
president and the opportunist in future
just talk about how we can build on the
relationship that we would hear okay
so we'll move on into new born you've
got your hand up your thinking your
worship just in regards to the community
strategy management positioned I made my
feelings earlier on and the piece about
its position I just hope that that it's
going to be value for money in today's
climate and what's happening out there
with the conversations I've had with a
few of our local ratepayers us employing
that position I don't think it's a few
people very happy so I will wait with
interest about what that role brings to
our community and hopefully it's a good
one apart from the rest of the budget I
think it's uh thank you very much so
you've done a good job
thanking you all and I take on board
concerns on the fears that that you are
expressing and I think that as a council
if we made a decision to invest in our
community then I believe that we've got
a responsibility to do that and that in
the best way we possibly can where we
think that the Ruby genuine payback not
just in financial terms but but on
financial terms but also in community
capacity building for the future and I
think this is an ideal opportunity for
that and well yes there's some dollars
involved here I think that the payback
will be tenfold over a period of time
and and I've got absolutely no doubt the
tussock country will develop into
something that is an icon for
not just this district but a national
icon it's got so many unique features
and and some some real potential that I
think will be built on so it's certainly
my views around there go endorse the
comments that have been made about the
work that's done to get us from six
point seven two two two point eight
eight four I think there's been a lot of
sweat and toil gone into getting to that
point and I and I know that there and
quite a number of things that both
council staff and counselors were hoping
for to be included but now it's just not
the right time and in my view what we
have before us is a that's a responsible
in a fair budget and and hopefully one
that we can we can continue the progress
that we have made over recent years it's
interesting that we are know and such a
tight on financial timeframe yes the
projects that we some of the biggest of
this council is ever seen and some of
the most necessary that this community
is ever ever seen a witness and but I
just hope that we can get through all of
those without too much pain and
suffering and also that there will be
support from government come along I'm
very hopeful that that that will happen
and hopefully this week might see some
some progress on that month okay and
other comments or questions around the
budget cancer
Dixon sorry dear the end up Dennis yes
you worship none of us like or want to
read rise especially at this time when
all ratepayers are feeling a pinch
central government legislation which
requires compliance of local bodies and
the council's committed costs in we also
know that borrowing puts the burden on
generation so I really I feel a small
but necessary rates rise 2.84 is is
fiscally responsible and I and I
congratulate those that worked hard to
bring that down 2.84 I also I have a
question just regarding the amount
agreement and I'm wondering if it was a
binding agreement or was that just like
a gentlemen's handshake I'm just
wondering about that how they could just
say we're not going to pay this now
would like to think that the binding of
be nice if it was but yes I think from
memory it was an email exchange between
myself and the former general manager
which reflected a fairly close
relationship between two public bodies
so there's no agreement that we can hold
MLT to task two it was it was a email
exchange and we feared it has been in
existence for around about nine years
and has operated were there any
difficulty in their time hands up but I
think there may be from the past yeah
yeah
thank you you worship and I just want to
say increases and thank you for taking
the time to explain a bit more about
what the tacit country and the community
strategy manager would actually do I
hope that we can see some progress in
the coming months for those positions
and I really hope that we'll see some
true benefit for the community so thanks
Steve and the staff for delivering a
good budget in or guess we'll just have
to try and keep that budget in the
budgets that the council staff
and you need to keep close on those
because things aren't going to improve
for the next 12 months announcement so
thank you and thank you Nikki and and
can I say that the hopes that you've
expressed so exactly the same hopes that
I have and I'll be doing everything I
possibly can to make sure that any money
that we're spending does seem to be
fading for birdie for money and there is
going to be a good return from there
duck you wanted if they come here thinks
your worship
this actually is more like an ad
everyone has si doing that there needs
to be seat the air and seriously the
business sector retail sector and Gore
is in a very very dicey position at the
moment as we all know by the headlines
in the South I'm just warning fans there
will be lots of jobs were predicted
losses and jobs and sector but this this
is a very I think it's a it's a good
budget I can see the point of having the
community officer there the community
strategy manager we did we have had a
lot of stuff across the line as far as
shovel-ready projects in or before that
the provincial growth function generally
through the the two employees that were
employed by the mayor's office and
they're now gone so we do yeah I do back
there and turn my head up to Steve a
Donna for floor you're getting at the
end a 2.84 that would have been nice to
see two point six for that there wasn't
to me okay that's me thank you don't
think we've covered everybody now so if
there's nothing further
would somebody like to move the
recommendations we have on page 21 it's
a two-part recommendation move that
councilman Krause is there any further
discussion
there's not I'm going to put that motion
all those in favor please say oh I end
up against the motion is carried
Thank You counselors thank you out for
the focus the questions and also the
endorsement is going to get us to this
point
okay and just to move on to the next
item which is the local government's
statement review and we have a memo from
the chief executive another one of these
formalities that that does need to occur
and it's pretty well lady out there what
and what it's all about just very clear
to what we are what it focuses like this
Steve do want to make a comment do
yeah thanks reshipped this is a three
year Lea exercise the council's need to
do which is it's really it's an a
feature that came through in the 2002
act when it was enacted to give the
public the information they need on how
their council operates and how they can
participate in the democratic function
of the local council so this is just an
updated document that we obviously
following election you put in place the
new elected members and take out those
that are no longer on the council any
changes in senior management and really
it's just an informative document we're
a little bit late this year
I guess floods in covert 19 have
conspired but we're supposed to have it
done by about mid April where we were in
midst of lockdown but there's nothing
particularly controversial worship there
is obviously a little reference on page
46 of the ginger or 20 the statement to
recognize that there has been some
changes in the and the offing and
respect of eboo liaison yet to be a
clearly articulated but it's a statement
of where we were at the moment but apart
from that you worship it's pretty much
business as usual and as for your
adoptions so it can
post on our website as an
information-based for the public to
excess and just a question I was read
standby castle McNally last night just
in terms of listing our committee from
there I know some committees have been
listed in full but some the three main
ones that we have now wouldn't risk
Kippur works and community strategy only
hear the cheers there's a requirement to
have all the council appointees and
those committees included or is it
that's three worship that's very just a
matter of personal choice
if you become we can add the individual
members of each committee into the
document there's no hassle whatsoever
okay see we've got a couple of hands up
councillor grant thank you did you
comment now that was that for the last
time okay you're on mute Glynnis thank
you your worship I'm wondering if we
have a statutory requirement to deal
with both tier Maremma and Hakka Nui
rune on earth why can we deal with one
or the other I'm just it's not very
clear and this document as yet but I see
it's being looked at yeah I'm not sure
we really really really understand what
the way forward will look like and from
connecting with both those organizations
and so hopefully we can make some good
progress on on the not too distant
future thank you
Brahman shall worship I notice on page
43 the council organizations is aligned
through the Community Counseling Center
but there isn't an update of the name
and that's the core and districts
Community Counseling Center I think that
might need to be included thank you okay
do any other alterations required of
this document there's not so with those
comments in mind with somebody like to
move that the local government statement
be adopted and made available to the
public counsel read and signature
counselor folks all those in favor
please say aye
against the motion is carry will be a
line up at the door in the five which is
rethinking rubbish recycling the waste
minimization which has been an
interesting subject over the last a
while and one that will continue to
attract lots of advice and comments on
tour from a wide variety but I mean this
Peter say that it is an area that is
incredibly challenging not so much
challenging in the way of management but
in said certainly in time the the
opportunities for recycling had become
very very limited in fact non-existent
in many cases which I really am unhappy
about however I don't know there's too
many options that council have right at
the moment and I'd like to think that
any decisions that we make tonight would
be decisions that are probably more of a
temporary situation that are in a
long-term situation and when the
recycling opportunities both offshore
and onshore become much more viable then
this council would take a leading role
and making sure that we're achieving
recycling to the best of their ability I
know that it has been an awful lot of
effort Council over the past four or
five years to
educate and encourage people to to
recycle and then I hope to say that
people have really taken that on board
and want to do it and asking them to cut
back in that area now or changed what
they've been doing it doesn't come
easily to them or to me which is council
want to do but to just have another
discussion about what we're currently
doing what is the best way to move
forward and that's really what this is
all about so they're too much ready Luke
and ice-t
do you want to just talk us through this
particular situation we find ourselves
in now and talk to the recommendation or
the options that you're asking Council
to consider tonight
yeah thanks your worship I mean to
endorse what you've said the choices
open to the council there and respected
recycling had been falling away at an
alarming rate in recent months in one
thing the council has committed itself
to is to be realistic and honest about
what it can expect consumers to do and
that if we're saying put it in that bin
that we want to make sure that it will
be recycled and it won't end up in a
landfill the last couple of months the
council has as quick as has been able
again given the flood events in over 19
and the impending end of the current
cube side or the recycling contract with
ste is to figure out what is a way
forward for the council and the interim
and the big thing here to emphasize is
that there are a considerable amount of
energy I understand being expended at
national level to come up with a
national strategy for for recycling and
waste minimization so there each council
isn't forced to try and find the magic
solution in its own area because this is
about scale and an economics of of
having product
which one council trying to battle as
and its own right is always going to
struggle to achieve so we got to a point
where the council was happy to have
retained recycling to a degree
we're glass would go on a yellow burn
care board would find its way to party
key liens via specifically provided
reciprocals a medic or matera with the
balance of waste to be deposited in the
ribbon and significantly and I think
this is probably something that's some
as a public of peps over overlooked
green waste to be free of charged and
that now has as in place as we speak it
was put in place during the covert
nineteen alert levels for and then
continued thereafter so when our a
situation where we've got a lot of waste
potentially going into red burn and not
a lot of waste go into the yellow burn
at the time of the last council meeting
where the proposal was approved it's
fair to say some counselors had
reservations about whether we had the
balance right between the two red bin
collections per month and two yellow
burn collections per month and the
thought at that time was to put and
place the proposal as it was presented
particularly because it was retaining
the cyclic nature of the current system
whereby the two ribbons the ribbons
entered every other week and likewise
the elements however it appears that
once we started to communicate this
proposal to residents and the ingore
Mattera
there was a fair bit of concern about
the ribbons adequacy to take all the
extra refuse and only having a twice
month's service so we've looked at that
and thought we've got enough time if the
council is of a mind to see if we can
offer some relief and but like a lot of
things
never a perfect fit and there's never a
perfect solution because there is always
in pace at this case the impacts are
twofold one is cost if you want to go to
a weekly Redburn service and still
retained a yellow burn monthly service
that would be an extra cost of about one
hundred and eleven thousand dollars we
believe if we have three collections per
month and one yellow band collection per
month three red one yellow the cost
increase would be negligible about
fifteen thousand potentially depending
on the extra waste that may go to the
landfill and I think this conversation
you worship needs to emphasize that we
have an obligation for waste
minimization it's under the waste
minimization Act but even if you are a
doubting Thomas and wasting waste
minimisation the one thing that is very
real is the waste minimization living
it's going upwards as it's moving from
twenty to sixty dollars per ton over a
period of two or three years so coming
soon to a place near us is a high tariff
for just chucking things in a rent burn
and forgetting about it so it behooves
us both teams a statutory obligation but
also in trying to encourage cost
minimization amongst our ratepayers to
see if we can minimize our waste so for
that reasons that reason we believe that
the most responsible overall approach is
to up for option two on the report which
is a three ribbon collection service one
yellow per month yes it will provide
some discomfort to consumers who have to
wrestle with one fortnight where the
errors no soon as the ribbon but the
thought being is that maybe some Rison's
can put aside some of those plastics and
Tim's if they're peps wash currently and
if they're not dirty you smelly they can
be put to one side and then spread over
a two-week service of the ribbon but Ric
it's not perfect but it's probably the
best solution we can come up with and it
mirrors the suggestion put forward by
one of the counselors when we hit last
meet and discuss this matter a month or
so ago hey thank you thank you Steve
three hands up all right here so Paul
reading the agenda argument it became
clear to me or I felt it was clear that
we possibly haven't articulated to the
public why we've made these changes now
councilor Davis and myself
representatives on waist net that manage
recycling and waste disposal regionally
and we are weird that there's been
massive changes as far as the recycling
or all markets are recycling they
they've just evaporated and the regional
present provider will no longer be a
provider come a 30th of June so we're in
a situation where we have to make
significant changes the initial project
proposal or council to have you know a
to weekly collection of red buns I think
as a result as provoked quite a lot of
comments so I think the second option of
collecting on a month three redundant
collections and one yellow bird and
there's a very good compromise bearing
in mind it's a substantial reduction in
costs to write tires and of course we've
got to be very conscious a lot of us
that product that would have found its
way into reedburn was green waste and
that there is now being provided as a
free service so at no cost so it look I
think the option to proposal is an
excellent one and perhaps we've been a
little bit more remiss in not explaining
to the public why we've taken the step
there's been massive changes to
waste management and the opportunity to
do recycling in South London so I think
this is an excellent response and fully
supportive of options who don't
yeah thanks your worship Bob yeah this
is Stephen later - we we went down this
road a month ago the actual idea
originally came from councillor hoisted
through to ramesha be out doing a three
but one yellow been about three or four
months ago and it's just it seems like
social media is brought into the
attention where we were sort of elected
to do the job that's the way we went
last last time we discussed this
I got a query Steve on coming in from
the mrs. Kirk and regarding the media
and one of her statements on page 56 the
fourth paragraph up is a 240 beat a 240
litre bin for glass only is a waste
people wanted to know if they could
change to an 80 litre bin I mean it is
currently council policy for people to
only be allowed two bins the same size
but you know and just jump in there the
statements that you're talking of the
aeronaut statements from the statements
so so the brackets isn't coming from us
all coming from the person you want to
mine that are years so there is a I took
a couple of statements that were posted
on our Facebook feed is indicative of
what people were saying but it is
correct that currently the policy is
that people must have their sweeter to
Burns has to be the same size you can't
have say an 18 turban and a 12 240 litre
burn so that was my question so my
question is what's the difference
between
policy and boy law because it's not in
the boilers the boiler that were just
classes no nothing no mention whatsoever
of stating that they had tea in two buns
and sensor so weird is that weird we
cross over you yeah how did that come
that difference between this particular
policy relating to the policy is
something that the council's can change
is sees fit and generally speaking
policies are a bit more detailed the
bear in mind the bylaw often is geared
towards minimizing nuisance so if it's
not in the bylaw it means they're
council can if it chooses to change its
policy it just needs to be aware of the
impact of doing that change and so some
of our staff may have some views about
what their impact might be I'm
personally not aware of the rationale as
to why we don't allow differing sizes
but there may be some other staff that
could elucidate on that particular
matter that's that's my exact question
your worship
why don't they allow a different size
but because if you've got one person
that is not an alcoholic
Oh doesn't drink at all you're not gonna
use a 240 litre but you know they'll be
using small but that they may need a
large 240 litre been fully read read
rubbish so you know we need to sort of
have a look at that doing before this
will go through a very good point you're
right and this one that I was I wasn't
but I can see Nikki waving her hand
frankly if you comment you want to make
threatening he's thinking you worship if
we change if we change all the yellow
buns around town to small burns there's
a significant cost council so we would
have to find storage for all of those
larger than
and we would have to buy a swath of
smaller ones all of which would be a
significant cost beard mine when we did
buy the buns initially when everyone
went into the recycling we were able to
claim some of that back through the
regional delivery so some of the cost of
it was by the regional living for waste
management so that that's the rationale
if we go and change the buns now they'll
be a significant cost thank you we put
some place it was also a simplicity of
operation you know roughly the volumes
that required for each burn would be
would be similar what we're talking
about now is it's probably a change to
that buy them for the big so that's a
good point it would be interesting to
just see what the cost implication might
be and also the space space implication
for the other bins but we have some
other ends up thank you your worship
I think this what brings decor is a
bigger issue about the amount of waste
that manufacturers are costing
ratepayers and it's probably more of a
central government issue that needs to
be addressed and because the costs need
to be placed I think on the
manufacturers that are creating waste of
deal Northwest should be should be
addressed a point-of-sale dealt with you
there's been various attempts for that
to happen packaging Accord for the base
15 years ago which was going to solve
all of their problems didn't know that
there was quite a lot of this but could
I not listening to this government
perspective to to get to grips with a
long-term solution for that's going to
be ultimately waste minimisation is is
answer rather than just getting bigger
bins around food movement and doing
nothing and okay thinking you worship
just about we've been working with the
staff in regards to matera and now we're
working quite well coming along nicely
the question though is that a lot of
people I don't believe realize exactly
how much it cost to recycle rubbish and
in that discussion was brought up last
night Sophia do would you like to just
explain to the rest of the councillors
basically how much it cost two per ton
to recycle rubbish
can I ask that true that you worship
free worship just to give you an idea
for one hundred eighty-two thousand
dollars a year tissue to do the to
recycling pickups per month so it's
about one hundred twenty seven thousand
dollars per ton we pick traditionally
for every year we actually pick out
about eight hundred ton of recyclables
so you drive into 180 to 200
twenty-seven dollars just for a pickup
it costs about thirty one dollars a ton
to transport it from or to a beeline and
it costs as one hundred sorry I'm Kostas
a hundred and twenty dollars a ton in a
peel I'm casually drop it off so I'm
getting mixed up you may be long to take
to take it to self in disabilities as
thirty one dollars a turn to easily have
it processed ad cell from disabilities
as three hundred eight dollars a ton so
all up as five hundred in sixty six
dollars a ton from the curbside to
recycle finished and herein lies my my
question is that we have to formally in
is educate air district in the way that
we should and that is to minimize your
waste by not buying
plastics
etc the things that you can't recycle or
this is what's going to happen it's
going to go into the landfill and the
cost of recycling is expensive and we
just have to put it into the landfill
and that's the situation we're finding
ourselves in repeat IRA me - I make a
comment
you worship I think to add to the
comment of councilor Phillips and later
I would like to add some logistical
point of view basically the idea of the
initial proposal or report to the
community and strategy committee was to
do two cycle and not to change the
existing cycle of red bean was based on
the theory that currently we have about
800 tons of the recyclable material so
majority of that recyclable material is
glass and cardboard if we are trying to
isolate it the plastic and the cans and
metal contribute to roughly 10 to 15% of
the rubbish what the whole economics of
this solution is to request the
community to adjust that 10 to 15
percent within existing red bean cycles
so that way we can save some money but
then we have done further investigation
or critic our own computation of the
cost of the service they realized that
the providing three red bean cycles as I
mentioned before we wanted to observe
the behavior and our education pattern
to the community to make sure we told so
that was a fallback option to go for a
three cycle three red bean collection
and one yellow bean collection of the
glasses we know the fact that the
glasses will not be full with the
existing capacity of the 240 litre bin
but that option is kept open because
nationally government is still working
on the solution of recycling we don't
know what he was it's a fast rapid
change is happening in this area
Ministry of Environment there is a lot
of surveys and discussions and meetings
are going on how do we improve
rationally and develop some consistency
but there is nobody has come to a
conclusion yet this is the interim
solution so that we can work work and
operate within the fiscal of envelope
knowing our community being very small
it is a blessing we can do any changes
and implement it provided community
supports us we can continue to offer any
services community wants at a cost but
when we were discussing about the budget
the whole council and community is very
much putting a strong eyes on the
budgets and the cost of the rate
increase at the which they should be
respectful of that what strategies we
are coming out with finding
cost-effective solution within the
fiscal envelope so that we can fund
other activities within the district
ramesh he was saying that the cheapest
option is not always the best long-term
option and I know that what we're
talking about now we we shift to a three
empty of the ribbons and a month can
only ever be temporary solution there's
and indeed what we're doing now what we
have proposed previously as a temporary
solution but I guess it's it's a
striking they're happy medium that you
you have been able to convince the
community that we're doing the best we
can and that we've got a solution for
the short term and hopefully we're not
too much elapsing we'll get to a point
where we can get to a option is there
any other comments anybody our problem
we want to make upon it when you do end
up with a thank you you worship and I
just like to say that I can understand
the fact that people are but stressed
about the fact their ribbons will be
overflowing and I don't think we have an
option but to do option total if you'll
pardon the pun but the other thing is
turn I mentioned it last time was we
really need to be educating the people
around town to just minimize their own
waste and I just wonder if perhaps you
know err publicity officer this Anya
could actually do some work there once
things have settled a little bit just I
mean a lot of people don't you know
they'll recycle their cardboard the
small packaging and things well that's
not going to be an option now so maybe
we need to be thinking about you know
what we don't doing those that have
forests are they burner
to take up this room in the retreat burn
or what in and the fact that a lot of
the rubbish that was recycled I don't
think people in the community understand
that not all of it was recyclable anyway
because of dirty containers and things
like that but the other thing is - I
think if people are going to they want
to recycle but they have to be aware
that only public pressure will push it
at a higher level and I'm not talking
about Gore I'm talking you know a
further up the food chain so you have to
be talking to supermarkets and just
saying get rid of your plastics get rid
of the packaging that's on you and I do
notice just as an aside that I like the
hair away storage and I know council
Gardo and I'll be delighted to hear
there but I noticed that this last year
they've gotten quite a large package up
to a smaller box probably a third of the
size in cardboard and I think that's
that's maybe the way that some of these
companies may need to be to be thinking
about their packaging and that will only
come when consumers drive those issues
to other companies but a little bit of
publicity about what we could do may
help think exactly and I do support
recommendation - I agree with you in
terms of the HERA weights
rowboats option they do a fantastic job
and it's it's good big weights down
today I'd have to take point of
difference with you in terms of getting
further up the chain and then go out I
think you can't get any further up the
food chain and go but there's just a
view that I have I think unless there
are any other comments particularly
anybody wants to make I see cliff you've
just put your hand up is there something
else that I'm prepared to move the
recommendation you worship bearing in
mind option two is a fiscally it's a
slight improvement and the soil I call
with without the great cost and it's
it's a response in an interim solution
so happy to move the rig
you worship I do of a signal for them
you can okay so the number of people
wanted
so moved councillor Bolger seconded
council that we make a change to go to
option two and we communicate that as
effectively as we possibly in the very
near future with with the wider
community
okay now I see we've lost air
communications person I'm actually back
at the desk okay sneaking around
equality okay
did you wanna make a comment Sonya yeah
I just wanted to say that in response
thank you three thank you worship I'm
just in response to councillor II we are
working on quite an extensive
communication plan which includes little
drops to all the customers
there's a quite a lot of waste
minimisation education which is a third
and fourth wave so yeah watch the space
there will be quite a bit of publicity
here coming out about it thanks Anya
great okay so if there's no further
comment or question after that motion
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried that we go
with option two as is a way forward
I think the councillors I'm thinking for
that discussion and the input and it was
pretty Universal I think this is the
last item we have in committee so will
somebody like to move that we go back
into open agenda please